yo I just I just want oh I didn't you
know who Andrew Schultz is the comedian
no sir okay he had a Ralph was on his
show so he's got a podcast called
flagrant okay and they've played this
YouTube video it's on YouTube right now
okay it somehow has not been violated or
yanked down there's this gay dude who's
got a YouTube channel
and he shaves his whole [__] on
YouTube
and it's still on it's got 35 million
views and it hasn't been yanked it
hasn't been taken down this [__] is
insane because it's instructional so
y'all gone
they got a problem with me saying
specific words
you can't have a [__] twerking in your
video but this guy's whole [__]
busted open on YouTube oh I can't have
chickens fight but they got I they can
still have some have fun [__] hairy
ass booty hoe
bro it's [__] crazy though it's got
30 some odd million views what does it
look like
I was watching another podcast it was
blurred out don't lie I didn't look I
don't lie I mean we were watching now
what does it look like
If he if he's right-handed and he was
shaving with the left hand that's kind
of talent that's probably that's the
only reason why I see why it's on like
valid on keeping it up
hard yeah bro think of it dog that's
like that's like writing with your left
hand and you're right-handed your
[__] except you're shaving your
[__] wait you got to see this [__]
it's it's edited because I'm not gonna I
don't wanna find the real one right of
course that'd be weird why would you
wanna yeah I wouldn't want to see that
where the [__] is this clip
[Laughter]
Jesus
I don't even know where it's at whatever
there's a dude's [__] on YouTube
right now somewhere though summer I'm
sure if you want to find it you'll
[__] find it you sick [__]
when did you start doing the thing you
do with your tongue when you be
pronouncing it
my engineer says it sounds like you're
drumming when you rap yeah
uh maybe like um my mid teenage
Mitch I don't want to say my whole life
but so is it ours only like like you can
somehow roll your tongue no matter it's
like man it's bro it's really just
talking lazy just and then like I don't
fully pronounce say my words and then
the more aggressive I get it just come
out
yeah I think that's the best way I can
explain it
do it right now yeah
yeah
like have you ever like just been
talking to a [__] and be like hell yeah
let me get a really cute [__] yeah it
come out all the time that shit's fire
it's they come out they like that [__]
they say freaky [__] about that I mean I
think it's funny you know I'm saying I
think it's stupid but of course they
like it so who gives a [__] uh Texas is
on fire right now I do yes Texas has
always been on fire bro like every
favorite rapper of y'all is y'all's
favorite rapper my two favorite rappers
right now are you and big X the plug and
he's on on your album yeah but both of
y'all [__] that song can rap
your ass off who's the other guy on that
song big yabo oh yeah who's on tour with
big X yeah so I think they did that and
I think that's what introduced them to
like getting it in and uh I think uh
me and X had that song before both of us
blew up wow yeah and then we I just held
it for so long and then ended up [__]
with my boy Johnny and he got cuz over
there at the smoker Club so it was easy
to punch that in how did uh you end up
linking with uh Johnny shipes
uh my all right so look I started
[__] with my doggy Greg and then from
there you know what I'm saying we were
just doing [__] uh booking shows like at
the Lux and things like that taking it
one step at a time he ended up knowing a
dog named fee and uh you know that I
guess they were boys you know and fee
was the one that kind of connected the
dots for all of us nice yeah nice yeah
it's crazy too because like if you think
about like I feel like finally because
when I like when I was growing up
because I'm from Arizona right so like
we got I got family in Queens Queens
Creek queen Queen Creek yeah Phoenix
yeah Queen Creek yeah Queen Creek or
Queens queen Queen Creek Queen Creek
it's a neighborhood right it's a it's a
city like 45 minutes outside of Phoenix
yeah that's right it's like a suburb
where people like went out and built
houses yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah I had
some Kinfolk out there we have like
growing up like the low rider shows was
like I mean obviously MC Magic's from
Phoenix
did you guys [__] with MC Magic in
Tucson or in Texas
can be Riders and shoes oh yeah yeah
yeah yeah we uh we got the uh we yeah
yeah uh but it was like magic it was
little Rob it was like bash who's
Vallejo Texas representative pretty girl
oh yeah that was right yeah for sure
super no it's not auto-tune it's a talk
box he's got the it's a top box he got
the hose in his mouth
the Roger the Troutman are you [__]
me I'm not [__] you sir
that's crazy
it does Roger Troutman bro
the Robot Boys
look this food
this Fool's got [__] uh it's a talk
box bro
look this [__] is wait this is an
interview you don't want to see this
dog is that your boys
you're trying to clear a record pretty
girls we got we sampled that pretty I
gotta hear that yeah it's stupid hold on
you guys
where the [__] is this
here it is
yeah damn that's crazy man you should
hear that every morning see him freaking
the Box
so he'll be on stage with the [__]
body he's in that hoe
oh yeah
like a queen
that's hard
and he playing Keys bro
[Music]
yeah no that's hard yeah
yeah no you guys gotta [__] with magic
wait pretty girls pretty girls it's
pretty gross NB Riders MC Magic
Envy Riders
every ride
are you sure because that's his group
because if it's an Emmy writer song
you're gonna have to clear it through uh
upstairs
if it's a magic record then oh yeah no
that's wait pretty girl oh no attempty
Riders you're gonna have to clear that
[__] through upstairs records and they
will hit you what was the name of that
lady is it Joe Lopez the lady who ran uh
you wouldn't know
yeah upstairs records actually I believe
based in Houston so you guys uh the lady
who will be clearing that for you will
probably [__] I'm gonna depend houses
are up to him
look that is a great rule of thumb if
you're an independent artist drop it
until they tell you to take it down yeah
yeah
they might they might they might
pause pause
give me that ass little boy
is this like a [__] uh like a
ulterior uh ego of yours where you turn
into like redneck OT I don't know dog
like I think I just I don't know get
over here God damn it
I don't know man I'm just [__] weird
yo have you ever been to Beaumont Texas
uh I've been around it yeah I've been
there I have a cousin that lives there
and he says it's like this redneck
[__] yeah I ain't gonna lie I mean
it's you know yeah but he said it's like
redneck ghetto but it's yeah yeah but
it's a little bit of everything you know
it takes is a
yeah there you go
West Columbia is a b Camp Brazoria
County we're in the area where we at so
that's the area you're from I'm from Bay
City that's like a county over okay is
that when you say I'm from Dirty Bay
Dirty Bay okay because Bay City Dirty
Bay be careful
or the bay
um I like that dirty Bay so if you ever
hear me say be careful Texas that's
basically Texas
BYOB strip clubs in Dirty Bay
um we ain't got your gloves but in Texas
I feel like they're all bring your own
bottle yeah
I went to a strip club out there one
time and they were like we just sell the
ice bruh we just got eyes bruh that's
crazy yeah there's some byobs in Austin
for sure I went to it
in Austin yeah right yeah that was cool
my dad my dad he punched in with all
them boys but yeah I uh